a twelve-year-old boys among the latest
victims of the widespread flu epidemic
Dylan when it died on Tuesday now he is
one of three children in Florida who
have died this flu season after getting
the virus has killed more than 30
children nationwide since October our
dr. taryn Derulo's here with how this
epidemic compares with other outbreaks
this is very very frightening good to
see you as well good morning downing
well the flu kills thousands of people
nationally every year it's difficult to
judge just how devastating the season
will be until it's over in the past few
weeks federal health officials say
they've seen a rapid increase in flu
activity and warned the end of the
seasons outbreak is still months away it
was an aggressive form of the flu the
parents of 12 year old Dylan Winnick are
pleading for other parents to treat this
season's flu epidemic seriously his
mother's partner Mike Medwin can't
believe the virus could take Dylan away
you shrug your shoulders no way we're
healthy you know the kids playing soccer
he's strong ready to go to school
investigators are performing an autopsy
to determine Dylan's exact cause of
death he reportedly did not have a flu
shot his brother Sebastian says Dylan
was healthy and enjoyed playing outside
no family should feel the same pain that
we're going through right now while
states are not required to report flu
deaths in adults to federal health
officials they are required to report
flu deaths in children over the past
decade flu related pediatric deaths have
ranged from a low of 37 between 2011 and
2012 to a high of 288 between 2009 and
2010 so far this season the virus has
killed more than 30 children in at least
23 states but that number will likely
continue to rise flu season can continue
as late as May Rachael Orson is an
assistant professor of pediatrics at
Washington University School of Medicine
in st. Louis it's difficult to predict
what will happen with the curve of
influenza we certainly are seeing a high
peak right now and we don't know if
we're going to be on the way down from
that in terms of the number of cases or
if it's going to continue to be
transmitted a high level it's especially
important to take steps to prevent and
treat the flu because it can create
further health complications a study
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine this week discovered that
people with the flu is
specially the elderly are six times more
likely to have a heart attack during the
week after being diagnosed with a virus
than those who aren't so doctor
explained how the flu can cause a heart
attack so the flu can do several things
it can constrict the blood vessels it
increases the demand on the heart
decreases the supply if you have lower
oxygen in the blood it also causes this
inflammatory cascade and can increase
clotting all of that can take a plaque
in the arteries that's stable and make
it unstable especially if you're
dehydrated too or absolutely dr. Tara
neuroma thank you